I know my Matt went over to Benji to the
peloton exercise live we did yeah and he
was saying that Benji is really slow on
the bike like he's almost my biking and
I go with three rpm the Met told me you
don't listen to the instructor that your
complete [ __ ] [ __ ] like Benji
that's just you like you don't listen to
me don't listen to anybody and like and
then you go what why don't people like
me I don't understand I'm why am i met
said hey he goes to the class with you
you're slow on the bike and that you
don't listen to the instructor what's
the point of going well okay I got an
incredible workout looks nipples get
hard and here's the other thing my med
told me Benji showed up what late late
to the class
Wow I still beat him where is he
just let the man in
because if Benji comes in you can't get
rid of him he did actually beat me but
it's like his body barely has to move to
burn like a tremendous amount of
calories what do you mean beat you like
he went faster than you on the screens
in the class it tells you how many
calories you're burning well and he's
burning a lot of calories cuz he's got
so much water and fast that's what I'm
saying let me be kettles were barely
moving but his calorie count was wait a
second Matt yeah it wasn't just calories
and the bike doesn't know how much you
weigh or how much water you have my
total number was higher than yours
correct yes yes right good I was
sweating my ass off I was going like 120
revolutions per second or whatever and I
look over at Benji and he would be going
like petal petal so he's not even doing
what the instructors telling him but you
did tell me you purposely weren't you
were ignoring what the instructor said
to do when I sit in front like in other
words he's not to be supposed to be
pedaling at 100 because if he did what
the instructor said to do he wouldn't
have beaten you right yeah you know what
I mean he's not listening to what the
instructor says if you win at the end
there's anyway like 300 pounds at this
point ah
Benji but this morning to 42.8 can I
spend you about the being late thing
yeah what is that
well it was just weird I was curious the
class was at 12:45
I talked to Benji at 12:25 he said I'm
one minute away he didn't walk in until
thirty minutes and I get a report on him
he showed up today at work at 6:56 he's
playing with fire he knows it - what
happened today I came later skinny and
early get yourself settled in read the
paper come up with some ideas oh hey
there was something funny from that
still around you know how that thank you
no I had enough right now he or knowing
mark alright but